رفض وضع كيس على راسه لحظه تنفيذ حكم
الاعدام بحقه فيما كان عدد عقد حبل
المشنقه بنفس عدد الصواريخ التي ضربها على
اسرائيل هل صحيح انه عدد عقد الحبل حبل
المشنقه كان على عدد صواريخ التي ضربها
صدام حسين على اسرائيل هذا ما نقل من داخل
قاعه المحكمه قاعه الاعدام 39 39 نقطه
تفاصيل جديده وقد تكون غير معروفه لكم حول
اللحظات الاخيره قبيل اعدام صدام حسين
كشفها خليل الدليمي رئيس هيئه الدفاع
السابق عن الرئيس العراقي الراحل في لقاء
مع العربيه الدليمي راى ان عمليه اعدام
صدام كانت غوائيه
وتتجاوز الشنق هل مات شنقا فعلا
كانت عمليه اعدام عمليه غوائيه
يعني انت تؤكد لنا الشكوك حول
موته شنقا نعم عمليه غوغائيه عمليه اداما
من اطلاق الشعارات الى التهديد الى اخر
مرحله ادلني اوضح ان ضابطين من المخابرات
الايرانيه حضر عمليه التنفيذ الاعدام
وكانها رساله بان طيران هي من اعدمته وفقا
لتفسيره اما عن اللحظات التي تلت الاعدام
ادليمي كشف ان جثمان صدام حسين نقل الى
منزل رئيس الوزراء الاسبق نور المالكي
للتشفي منه في يوم زفاف ابنه نافيا في
الوقت ذاته ان يكون سبب نقل الجثمان الى
مدفن اخر نتيجه التنكيل بقبر صدام ماذا
حصل بالجثمان بعد الوفاه
نقل الى بيت نور المالكي تشفيا
في يوم زواج
نجله احمد
بعد بعد الاعدام مباشره بعد الاذان مباشره
جميع التفاصيل والاسرار التي كشفها خليل
الدليمي للعربيه اثارت ضجه وتفاعلا واسعين
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي رغم مرور نحو
17 عاما على اعدام صدام حسين